People forget things because of interference. They can also forget things
because of brain injury of disease. Forgetting things because of brain injury
or disease is what we call amnesia. Now, there's two types of amnesia that
psychologists study. The first is anterior grade amnesia. Someone with an
anterior grade amnesia can't remember anything after the onset of a disease, or
a brain injury. Do you remember HN that we talked about earlier in the lesson?
He had anterior grade amnesia. That was a perfect example of that. Now, the
second type of amnesia is retrograde amnesia. Someone with retrograde amnesia
can't remember anything before a brain injury, or before the onset of a
disease. Let's go to Greg to talk about a personal experience with both of
these types of amnesia.